PROFESSOR: So let's look now
at the mathematical foundations
of probability theory, the basic
definitions of which we've just
been doing examples
up until now.
So a key concept is
a probability space.
And that's what we're going
to talk about in this segment.
So the abstract setting
of a probability space
is the first thing you start
off with is the set of outcomes,
which is what we saw we
were doing with the tree
models in the previous videos.
And the condition
that we require
is that there should be a
countable set of outcomes.
So there's something
called the sample space.
And the sample space
is designed to model
all the possible
things that can happen
as the result of your
random experiment, all
the possible outcomes.
And we require that there
be a countable number.
Now, the examples
that we've seen so far
have only had a finite number.
But we will shortly
see a bunch of examples
where we really need
an infinite number.
But only a countable
infinite number.
That's part of the definition
of a probability space-- the set
of outcomes.
The next thing is a
probability function
whose task is to assign
probabilities to the outcomes.
So the condition is that the
probability function, Pr,
gives every element
in S, every outcome,
is going to be assigned a
probability of between 0
and 1 inclusive.
So every outcome gets a
probability between 0 and 1.
But the constraint on
the probability function
is that if I sum up
the probabilities
of all the outcomes-- omega is
an outcome in the sample space
S-- and I take the sum of all
of those probabilities of omega,
they have to sum to 1.
That's the crucial condition
that defines a probability
function on a sample space.
And the two together are what
are called a probability space.
A sample space with a
probability function
is a probability space.
So the purpose of the tree
model that we were using
is really to figure out which
probability space to use.
And the mathematics
doesn't really
start until you have
the probability space.
Up until that, it's the
modeling part that's
very important mathematically.
But you can't say that the
model is right or wrong.
It's a model, and its
rightness or wrongness
is a matter of
judgment and comparison
to how it stacks up
against reality and things
that we care about.
When we're using
the tree model, it's
the leaves of the tree that
correspond to the outcomes.
And the outcome
probabilities, which
are crucial for having
a probability space,
we got by reasoning
about the probabilities
to assign to each possible
branch of the tree
as you worked your
way from root to leaf.
So the other key concept
that we saw already
is the idea of an event.
An event, formally, is nothing
but a subset of the sample
space.
An event is some
set of outcomes.
Presumably, the
event is an event
that you're interested
in, like winning.
And the definition of the
probability of an event
is simply the sum of
the probabilities of all
the outcomes in the event.
And we were using this
already for both Monty Hall
and for the poker hands.
But this is the official
general definition--
that once we have a
probability function that
assigns probabilities
to outcomes,
then we can use that to define
the probability of an event.
This is the definition of
the probability of an event--
simply the sum of the
outcome probabilities.
And as an immediate corollary
of this definition, what we get
is something that's central
to probability theory.
It's called the sum rule.
And it says that if you
have a bunch of events that
are pairwise
disjoint-- so there's
no outcome in common to A0 or
A1 or A1 or A2 and so on-- then
the probability of the union
of the A's, the probability
that one of these events occurs,
one or more of these events
occurs, is simply the sum of
the individual probabilities.
And that is a rule that
we'll be using all the time.
It's very convenient
for computing things.
If you just break them
up into separate cases,
then you can handle the
separate cases-- each A0,
A1-- separately, and then
add up the probabilities.
And in some approaches to
probability, more general ones,
this is actually
taken as an axiom.
It's the axiom that defines
a probability space,
but where you start with an
assignment of probabilities
to events.
But in the discrete case, we
don't have to worry about that.
It's a corollary of the way
we define the probability.
And that, of course, is a
crucial rule-- sometimes called
the countable sum rule.
But we're just going to
call it the sum rule.
Expressed in concise
notation, it's
the probability of
the union of the Ai's,
as i ranges over the
non-negative integers,
is simply the sum of the
individual probabilities
of those events.
Now, why it's called discrete
probability that we're studying
is because we have a
countable sample space.
And as we saw, that
discrete combinatorics
is the combinatorics
of countable
and even finite sets, really.
The crucial reason
why we're sticking
to discrete probability
is that allows us to work
with sums instead of integrals.
If you start allowing
continuous intervals of time
and the probability,
say, of throwing a dart
and it landing at a given
interval on the line
and a whole bunch
of other situations
where it's natural to want to
use continuous probabilities,
you're forced into
defining a probability
in terms of integrals,
because every outcome
has probability 0.
And the theoretical basis
of it is considerably more
complicated.
And we don't need
it for, in fact,
virtually any purposes that
come up in computer science.
And so we will,
happily, not have
to study integral calculus
or measure theory, really,
and just get by with sums.
So let's quickly point out some
rules that are now corollaries.
They're really derived
rules of probability theory
that follow as a consequence
of the countable sum rule.
And the first one is
the difference rule.
The probability of
A minus B is simply
equal to the probability
of A minus the probability
of A intersection B.
Now, notice how much this
looks like the difference
rule for cardinalities--
that the cardinality
of the finite set A minus B
is simply the cardinality of A
minus the cardinality
of A intersection B.
And indeed, the
proof of this is just
like the proof of cardinality.
It follows directly
from the sum rule
for probabilities, which
corresponds, of course,
to the sum rule
for cardinalities.
Namely, by the sum
rule for probabilities,
what we know is
that A is equal set,
theoretically, to A
intersection B plus A minus b.
That is, A breaks
up into the points
that it has in common
with B and the points
that it doesn't have in
common with B. Since those
are disjoint, you can add them.
So the probability of A is
equal to the probability
of A intersection B plus
probability of A minus B.
And so I just transpose the A
minus B to the left hand side.
And I get the
difference rule, which
is a rule that's
worth remembering.
Similarly, we have
inclusion-exclusion.
If A and B are not disjoint,
then the probability
of A union B is equal
to the probability
of A plus the probability
of B minus the probability
of the intersection.
And the proof is,
in fact, exactly
like the corresponding rule for
cardinalities of finite sets.
And of course, it
generalizes to more sets.
This is an example of the
inclusion-exclusion for three
sets in terms of probability.
Another useful, it
turns out, consequence
is that the probability
that A or B happens
is guaranteed to be less than
or equal to the probability
that A happens plus the
probability of B happens.
And this follows as
a trivial consequence
of the inclusion-exclusion
rule for two sets,
because the probability
of A union B
is equal to this plus this
minus some probability,
namely, the probability
of the intersection.
So you're taking away
something non-negative
from these two in
order to equal that.
In particular, then, this must
be less than or equal to that.
And the closely related
phenomenon is [? basi-- ?]
[AUDIO OUT] The probability
that A or B happens
is greater than or equal to
the probability that A happens.
And finally, we
can generalize that
to a countable
collection of sets.
If I have a bunch of events--
A0, A1, and so on-- then
the probability that at
least one of them occurs,
the probability of the
union of the Ai's, is
less than or equal to the
sum of their probabilities.
This is, again, another kind
of obvious rule, not hard
to prove.
We're not going to
bother proving it,
because it really is obvious.
But we will get some
mileage out of it later on.
So to summarize, the key concept
here is a probability space.
It consists of a countable set
of outcomes, the sample space,
and a probability function that
assigns values between 0 and 1
to every outcome such that the
sum of the probabilities is 1.
And when we're using our
tree model and so on,
our objective is to construct
one of these things.
Usually, the hard
part will be verifying
that, in fact, the
way we've assigned
probabilities has the
property that the sum of them
is equal to 1.